cornered Rats start to behave really
erratically and that's what we're seeing
right now with the president as
questions continue to grow about Donald
Trump's mental and physical health as
his polling continues to collapse as the
world continues to point and laugh at
him as coronavirus tragically rages and
kills people in the U.S despite many
countries having it completely under
control Donald Trump has now wildly and
without evidence accused former
president Barack Obama of treason now
we've seen Trump now for a while go on
about Obama's supposed crimes remember
Trump talked for a while about Hillary
Clinton's supposed crimes that seems to
have been forgotten and Trump even said
not long ago that Barack Obama committed
the greatest political crime in American
history but when he was asked
specifically what was that crime he had
nothing that was then he has said now in
an interview that aired yesterday with
the Christian Broadcasting Network yeah
that the crime is treason let's take a
look here is a visibly sweaty and
disheveled Trump casually saying the
crime is treason the crime that Barack
Obama committed is treason also the
interviewer David Brody really makes me
cringe with his little interjections you
can tell Brody is one of these suck-ups
that just is desperate to be Trump's
friend here's Trump accusing Barack
Obama of treason on Obama and the spine
situation this idea that they were
spying in your campaign you've been
asked before about what crime he would
have potentially committed but I
remember you talking to treason
look look when I came out a long time
ago I said they've been spying on my
campaign I said they've been taping and
that was in quotes meaning a modern day
version of taping it's all the same
thing but a modern day version but
they've been spying on my campaign I
told you that a long time ago turned out
I was right let's see what happens to
him now
Durham is
I never met her because I want to stay
out of it because otherwise it's going
to look political
but Durham as you know is a highly
respected person and Bill Barr is doing
a great job as attorney general let's
see what they come up with but
they don't have to tell me all I have to
do is read the papers
the insurance policy in case she doesn't
win we've got insurance policy well that
was all the stuff that we went through
over the last let's say two and a half
years now we caught him we caught him
called struck and Paige the two lovers
Brennan and Clapper the way they lie
Democrats can't stand behold me
they they just they can't send who Bill
Barr they just think he's polite you
know why because he's doing such a good
job because he's Law and Order
but he's got them in his crosshairs and
now we have to see what's going to
happen I will say this if it were
reversed and if the other side said
we're at the Oval Office right in that
chair behind the Resolute desk and it
was the opposite
two years ago
25 people would have been convicted and
they would be sent to jail for 50 years
so I want to remind you we are
experiencing hypernormalization so I I
have to State unequivocally this is not
normal a president accusing a former
president of treason is not normal and
it is outrageous Trump has possibly just
months left in his presidency hopefully
and he is focused on let's see what
William Barr comes up with on treason by
Obama and the Obama Administration now
just to give you a little context
treason laws in the United States exist
at the federal level there's also State
treason laws the definitions are pretty
similar
in Most states the treason statutes are
similar to federal law and it's about
levying war against the United States
helping the enemies of the United States
giving Aid or Comfort to enemies of the
United States only 30 people in history
have been charged federally with treason
under those laws extremely rare it's
wild it's wacky it's embarrassing for
Trump to say it about Barack Obama they
never actually had the goods and this is
a continued sign of desperation now I
want to remind you here is what Trump
said when he was asked by the Washington
post's Philip Rucker This was
it was either three years or three weeks
ago it's hard to tell right now no I
think this was during the last four to
six weeks uh Philip Rucker asked Trump
when you talk about obamigate what crime
are you alleging was committed and
Donald Trump says come on Philip you
know what it is take a look it's the
president in one of your Mother's Day
tweets you appear to accuse President
Obama of the biggest political crime in
American history by far those were your
words what crime exactly are you
accusing President Obama of committing
and do you believe the justice
department should prosecute him
uh obamigate it's been going on for a
long time it's been going on from before
I even got elected and it's a disgrace
that it happened and if you look at
what's gone on and if you look at now
all of this information that's being
released and from what I understand
that's only the beginning uh some
terrible things happened and it should
never be allowed to happen on our
country again
and you'll be seeing what's going on
over the next over the coming weeks but
I wish you'd write honestly about it but
unfortunately you choose not to do so
yeah John please what is the crime
exactly that you're accusing him you
know what the crime is the crime is very
obvious to everybody all you have to do
is read the newspapers except yours a
true classic moment of the Trump
Administration it's really really
terrible that it happened right but Mr
President what is it that happened you
know what it is you know what it is I
guess now Trump is saying that what
happened is treason so now that we've
got the sort of facts out of the way
let's take a step back because I do
think there's an important element of
hypocrisy to point to here and hypocrisy
no longer matters to the American right
maybe it never did as as president
Donald Trump has insisted time and again
he can do whatever he wants he can say
whatever he wants to whoever he can do
whatever he wants he can't be
investigated these have been the
positions of the Trump Administration
Trump's entire presidency has been based
on the president can do whatever the
hell the president wants period it's
sort of a a version of Nixon's if the
president does it it's not a crime on
steroids so if that's the case
couldn't Barack Obama have done whatever
he wanted while he was President how is
it that Trump can do whatever he wants
and can't even be investigated but
William Barr can be investigating Obama
for treason now what Trump might argue
is well I'm a sitting President Obama is
no longer president except Trump has
previously argued this never should have
even been allowed to happen while Obama
was President and Trump of course
believes he shouldn't be investigated
after being president for things he did
while President so it's complete and
total hypocrisy now my question to you
is I researched this today couldn't find
any examples has any uh president in
modern American political history
accused a former president of treason I
wasn't able to find any examples I'm
asking you for help if other presidents
have done this please let me know and we
will be covering this extensively on the
show's Instagram at David Pacman show
also make sure you're following me on
Instagram at david.pakman if you want a
break from the politics I have a picture
of myself holding a teeny tiny puppy
over the weekend it's on my Instagram at
david.pakman it's a beautiful message of
peace love and understanding in tough
times uh or it's just a funny picture of
a puppy you be the judge
one of our sponsors
nordvpn is giving you 70 off a
three-year plan which comes out to just
a little over three bucks a month and
you'll get an extra month free when you
go to nordvpn.com davidpackman or just
go to their site and use the coupon code
davidpackman it's 2020. there is really
no reason not to be using a VPN not
using a VPN means you are not taking
your Internet safety seriously I use
nordvpn almost any time I'm using the
internet it hides your IP address when
you're browsing online keeps you safe
from hackers keeps websites from
tracking your browsing activity many
advantages and nordvpn is the most
trusted VPN in the game they don't log
your internet activity like many other
vpns do their servers are super fast and
you can even use it on your phone
nordvpn is giving you 70 off a
three-year plan that's just over three
bucks a month plus an X extra month free
when you go to nordvpn.com
davidpackman I've put a link right
underneath the video or just go to their
website and use the coupon code
davidpackman